welcome back everybody happy
Halloween I'm K and Kyle Richards
and our next guest is a very very funny
man you've seen him on wild and out and
you can also see him now as the host of
celebrity squares Tuesdays on bh1 it's
your got DC Young Fly host of the new
celebrity squares let's talk about these
topics what's your favorite Poe don't
have me do a hand stand up here on this
platform let's talk about these prizes
correct
oh and can we talk about these
celebrities y'all make some noise for
Miss
T I'm done talking let's play I love the
game please welcome DC youngfly
[Applause]
everybody
we're vampires We are family is it hard
to talk for you yes I can't say nothing
I know I have to comment on this is not
it's your normal costume you look so
sharp every episode man I love how you
dress yes that I know
I I do I love how you dress it's like
it's so sharp I love it yeah I had I had
I had to you know what I'm saying step
it up you know what I mean put on the
soup you know I mean take the street
clothes off of this you know sharping up
a little
bit so wait did you get into costumes
when you were a kid I tried to do a
little something something see I'm this
a real vampire see back in the day we I
couldn't be the the real vampire like we
had the teeth but I ain't never had a
cape or none of that stuff you know we
got our teeth from Family Dollar so so
these teeth right here this the longest
the teeth have ever stayed my mouth I we
did we did the Family Dollar as well I
was like people were like we're going to
party city I'm like you're rich like we
daring we had the one that go up top and
the one that go on the bottom like you
can see it when we talking and it like
came out as you were talking I was I
Spit on every connected I know I know I
think I Spit on Kyle earlier and I was
like oh my God so much saliva I'm just
saying do you see Keith I
know wait so I imagine you were like the
class Clan have you always been like a
little comedian have you always man I
always you know had good sense of humor
you know what I mean just coming up from
the west side of Atlanta you dig what
I'm saying but you know I never thought
I was going to be a comedian no I never
thought but you know when God directed
my foot path you know what I mean my
steps I just kept on going you dig yeah
well God will give you opportunity you
have to take the opportunity and
opportunity and put it in the choke
hoold have you ever been since since you
weren't always into it have you ever
been like St have you ever had stage
right like been scared on it's not you
know I come from theater so you
know all right all right got some
theater Mes in here that's sir so I come
from theat so it wasn't never you know
hard for me to adjust I just never knew
that I was had to be a comedian first
cuz I did com I mean I did music so I
never knew that like I had to tell jokes
for a living yeah but wait but I have to
ask even with theater though I knew
friend like I wasn't ever like really
stage fight but I had friends that were
terrified even in theater like no like
this right here like I love this like
this right here you see this
see you got you got to know how to own
that right
there so that's part of theater see
people don't understand that y'all are
part of the emotion so when we on stage
when we hear y'all every time we do
something we hear y'all to the actors
that's on stage we like maybe we should
get more deep into what we doing because
the audience is letting us know like I
feel you they're responding yeah right
yeah have y'all ever been stage right oh
yes sure I got it right
now therapy for my S did you say you
went to therapy for I went to
hypnotherapy for yes I did does that
work cuz I'd really like to not love
sugar um I think it works I did you know
did also for flying my fear of flying oh
I used to have a huge fear of flying you
scared of flying not anymore okay the
hypnotherapy worked okay you know what
helped me a bit is I took um lessons in
flying I was terrified at first I'm not
that fair less like so you got
hypnotized I
did so like watch out if we like clap
twice she might clect like a chicken
yeah like go
out so wait so hosting celebrity squares
is this fun you look like you're having
so much fun L it I'm trying to I want to
bring all y'all on to the show you going
come to the
show you come you going to call I'm
there see this what I'm talking about
that's all only if I can play against
them that's all it's about you know I
it's it's just a family oriented show
you know what I'm saying it's a it's a
game where we play tit tattoe but we got
so many people that's on the the the the
cast like Chico Bean you know what I'm
saying Carlos Miller we even got baby
face I love baby face love baby face
keep you know baby baby oh that
baby but but we we we don't brought such
of a great energy you know what I'm
saying the VH1 and I feel like you know
celebrity square is going to be here for
you know 10 plus years yeah people love
to tune in for like a fun game and
everybody kind of out of their element
seeing them do something else I love
that and not only that you can you can
be yourself cuz you know we all got jobs
but we also like we want to have fun too
so it's like what show can we come on
that we could just chill have fun you
have fun you have fun no it is ke that's
cuz you're always talking about death
man every night I just watched you last
night for three hours was that talking
about death
yes I don't have
either wait I have to ask though when
did cuz I did not think I would be a
host ever did you have like any kind of
learning C like thing that happened you
were like woo okay but see when you when
theater when you that why I'm glad I
come from theater because it's like
improv when it's like a monkey ranch
when some when somebody throws some out
there you got to adjust fast yeah so
when I'm when I'm doing the hosting it's
just more so me being in my head say how
can I be the best host right now if I
was a host who who am I and why would I
be hosting and I had to bring that
energy I don't never limit myself you
know I always feel like I could do
anything especially God keep waking me
up every morning I'm I'mma go to work I
love it I love it all right we need
another commercial break but you can
catch DC youngfly host celebrity squares
Tuesdays on
[Music]
[Applause]
bh1
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home